well good afternoon everyone and for
those of you that I didn't have a chance
to say hello to earlier i'm deb dehaas
i'm a partner at deloitte vice chairman
and lead our center for corporate
governance and you know on behalf of my
joy colleagues I just want to thank all
of you for being here today we're very
proud to be the platinum sponsor of the
milstein Center and I'd like to you know
personally thank I rub bill Marcel the
entire team at milstein as well as
Colombia and all the speaker's here
today for just doing a wonderful job and
I think it'd be great if we could give
them all a big round of applause
terrific day I also just wanted to
comment on how exciting it was to see
all the honorees and the award winners
here today I think we can all feel very
confident that the future leaders of
corporate governance it's a very bright
future indeed and I also know that it's
always high risk to be that person
that's standing in between the end of
the day in cocktails so I will be very
very brief and maybe just comment on a
couple things that I took away from the
day today again it was a really
interesting dialogue and I think bill
you started off the morning wonderfully
with talking about us being at this
inflection point on governance and I
think certainly today we heard many many
things that I know i'm going to ponder
as i leave here tonight but i think
three important things that i'll just
share with you that i took away first of
all just the crown database that is a
spectacular investment and outcome by
milstein and columbia and i think truly
has an opportunity to change the face of
fact based research in governance so i
know i'm really excited for us to
deloitte and others to have the
opportunity to have access to that going
forward second just a tremendous
conversation around board governance
what's happened a lot of comments about
the sophistication of boards
governments practices inside
organizations but I think clearly from
what you heard across the board those
expectations are only going to increase
going forward and so I think the
importance of us all continuing to focus
on you know what's the real work of the
board the time that needs to be put in
the importance of ongoing board
refreshment composition making sure
bringing the right skills particularly
those deep industry skills and they need
to bring that activist mentality into
the boardroom to make sure you're really
maximizing the value of the organization
and then just really last I think just
that really interesting tog I think
we're going to continue to see between
long term and short term and I thought
the last panel did a wonderful job about
talking about the array of shareholders
and the different perspectives that they
do bring but I really thought bill had a
great comment about what he sees as
being that opportunity for both
long-term shareholders and boards to
collaborate together as well as with
other shareholders to really drive
long-term value and and and good within
our businesses of the future so again I
was really a pleasure to be here today
I'm sure you all wash away with many
insights as well before I turn it over
to IRA I know we're going to be leaving
in a moment and invite you to join us
for cocktails and the faculty lounge and
very importantly for those of you who
are looking to get CLE credit from today
it's really important that you stop by
the desk on the way out and sign out so
that you receive credit for that time
today thanks so much it was a privilege
to be here
I appreciate the ability to be here at
the very end to congratulate the
audience for hanging in I know you're
not here just for the cocktails that you
stayed for the substance which is really
great I wanted to thank a lot of people
for what's going on and then i'll give
you my my own wrap up which is really
very simple first of all these things
don't happen magically this is the best
forum i can remember in the 10 years
we've been doing it and the reason is
number one we have focused in on
substance in a consistent way number two
we have a group of speakers who are
unparalleled I've never seen such a
distinguished group of people come up
from the head of the round table to alan
murray take cab every one of them gave
up that time to come from very business
busy practices to columbia and that that
was to me amazing we I don't remember
having attended or put on a panel show
like this it's been amazing to have the
group that we have in the audience by
the way is pretty good too we have a
fine audience this time composed of a
lot of people who actually do it which i
think is great it means that corporate
governance is getting serious and we're
now seeing people come to meetings like
this who are seriously practicing one
way or the other in it so the magic of
getting you all together and the magic
of getting a series of speakers together
together the way we have that doesn't
happen so automatically first of all I
want to help thank the Columbia faculty
which were which work with us to put
together the ideas to make a consistent
series of panels which hung together and
they did this is great and it's the
reason why we're at Columbia because we
have a faculty which is devoted to this
intellectually in a real
wise and capable of reaching out to
people such as you and the speakers and
bringing them all together so I'm really
thrilled and I'm back at Columbia Ben
and back at a place where people are
really interested in what we're doing
and the future is bright because the
faculty is getting even more involved
than they have been in the past and now
what I should say too is as far as
putting together the faculty the group
and getting you all in the same room and
getting the speakers up it wouldn't have
been possible without our executive
director myself just a secure who's in
the back of the room has been scurrying
around I he's a recent acquisition and a
very good one and we're looking to many
many more years Marcel and rosemary do
to me who's been his assistant and
working with him and producing food and
people and all the other things that go
along with Thank You rosemary so lastly
what did I get out of it but I got out
of his a new chairman that's
unbelievably good so Phil I'm glad
you're here I look forward to picking as
far as as far as substance is concerned
it's been amazing because it all hangs
together at least I've been watching
carefully each of the panels and what I
got out of it is this number one we have
an array of shareholders for sure who
are quite different people evaluate them
differently some of the people who came
up said well is really no problem the
long run will take care of it freedom of
no on that's fine but actually we do
have not a problem but we do have issues
we have a lot of different shareholders
and we have a lot of different aims and
agendas of these shareholders they're
activists and activists and there are
great pension funds and there are great
Mutual's and there are great investment
managers they all have a view now those
are all shareholders and I think we put
them on display today so
really very good people who really
believe in what they're doing and and
then are doing it right by their lights
which is very important but they're
different from the other shareholders in
in turn what I learned I learned that
they are different I knew they were
different but putting a face on the
difference I think for you and me and
others is extremely important what do
they all have in common the one thing
they seem to have in common is they want
good boards each one of them wound up by
discussing how important it was to have
actually engaged boards and good boys
and I think all of them have agreed that
we've got a way to go before that
happens we'd have a we haven't got yet
the kind of boards which make everybody
happy we need them then we talked about
what kind of boards they would be and
here's where the tough subject really
gets tougher because to define the
directors who are going to be on these
very good boards that we all want coming
from an array of shareholders all of
whom whether they're activists of
rituals or pension funds all of them
want good boards and better boards and
they're all going about it in different
ways but that's what they want and
that's what we have to produce so now
how do we produce through good
governance which is what we're all about
we am quite produced yet we've got a way
to go how are we going to produce those
boards which everybody seems to want and
everybody is fighting for in their own
way the answer is I don't know and
that's why we have the centre actively
involved and now beginning to plan the
project on the bill or I'm going to help
when others will help as well to try to
figure out what will we define as a good
board can we is there a profile can we
create a profile we know that it's going
to change over time no privacy no
profile is consistent who do we want on
the boards what do we want them to
what kind of people are we looking for
this is a major project and I'd like to
leave you with the thought that it is a
major project it's all well and good to
talk about we want good boards it's all
well and good to talk about the fact
that good boards will make for better
corporate governance and deal with the
array of shareholders in their own way
and they'll all be consistent with the
idea of creating a long way profits
wealth whatever you want to call it for
the shareholders how do we get there how
do we do that nobody can do that on
these sins platform or any other
platform nobody is able to define the
mechanics are going about creating a
good boy access fine what its access
lead to who do they going to put on the
board what are they how are the excess
sores going to find out the kind of
people that we want and put them on the
boards how are the activists go to find
the kind of people that they want how
are the pension funds and the mutual is
going to find the kind of people they
want I don't know and first we have to
try to define what it we're talking
about which we haven't yet other than
saying we want good boards who are
engaged what kind of people are they to
find that it's not going to be easy to
do that this is the future of the center
we now have the job of trying to define
the projects which will produce the good
boys we hope it's not going to happen
overnight it's going to take a lot of
time and if we finally get around to
doing it how are we going to get those
good boards in place my own view is that
the boards are very responsible for good
boys better but that's that's short
circuiting in it and there will be a lot
of that involved too namely after we
know how to do it what we want how do we
get them there what is it that's going
to give us the ability to replace what
we have and improve it now finally what
I got out of it is how important crown
and its algorithms are I don't
understand those algorithms at all all I
know is it
do produce information not data and the
kind of information in crown and Rob
showed you this morning is just
scratching the surface but think how
important it is now that we're thinking
about the motivation of shareholders
want good boys do they really want good
boys they want something else we can
find out now we have the ability to do
that how many good boards are there we
have the ability to find that out once
we know what a good board is in other
words these algorithms are going to give
us the ability to get into data which is
there it's there and a whole variety of
places but nobody's been able to access
it and make it information crown can do
that so we now have the center operating
on a very good investment in the crown
which is going to produce results for
all of us and a future which can be
helped a lot my crown so I want to thank
everybody who's here having stuck it out
and build particularly for taking over
and everyone else who's been involved
and I really appreciate the office
hanging in the audience hanging in as
long as you have and I I applaud you for
your stick-to-itiveness it's really
great thank you all